all right guys
what's up bang bang it's lunch
money time while while she's trying to
get rich
the rest of us is trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here
virtually with the beautiful intelligent
plena evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p what up pimp
she's gonna be on monday
to back in the kitchen it'll be great
uh let's see block five is now a sponsor
of lunch money
go get a block five account if you don't
have a blackfy account at this point
you're a loser
here's a loser that's it go get a block
fly account you can earn
8.6 apy up to 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account go
get one
only losers don't got an account at
blockfly
go get one blockfi.com pomp
do your research go look at it ain't
nobody ever looked at it and been like
oh this is stupid
so go to your research blockfy.com don't
be a loser get a blockbuy account
all right i'm good ready yes
uh the sun is coming in real interesting
here angel don't worry
um stocks fell on friday with wall
street
set to wrap up a difficult week as u.s
fiscal
as u.s fiscal stimulus stocks broke down
coronavirus cases rose and a slew of
companies reported quarterly earnings
so the stock market ain't so hot right
now they don't like
that political uncertainty who doesn't
like it the investors
investors ain't got nothing to do with
coronavirus
it ain't got nothing to do with stimulus
actually it probably does have something
to do with
antivirus and stimulus too but i
personally think that nobody wants to
talk about the fact
i'm willing to bet i'm willing to bet
that because the polls are showing
that maybe the candidate who ain't so
great for rich people
and corporations might win that might
have something to do with it too
so we'll see was it tuesday night is
election day
tuesday election night yeah it's gonna
be wild
are we gonna watch it live are we gonna
stay up and watch it
should we live stream it no i might
no we're gonna okay you and me will
chill in our apartment with a bottle of
wine
and we'll watch it or six go ahead or
six okay um
okay so okay
i'm just trying to get it to load so
speaking and now somebody from bethlehem
pennsylvania is calling me i don't know
what's going on okay
and the manger what bethlehem jesus in
the manger
okay ready so that you're speaking of
the u.s
election americans aren't the only ones
obsessed
with the election british bettors
are wagering a record amount of money on
the u.s presidential election
dwarfing the amount wagered on any
sporting event
or even their own nation's politics as
of when
as of wednesday morning 220 million
pounds or about 284 million dollars
had already been wagered on the betfair
exchange
and it's a that's a london-based company
operating the world's largest
online betting exchange and
that tops the previous record of 199
million
pounds fed on the trump clinton race
four years ago why do you think the
british are betting on an election
because they got nothing better to do
nah i mean look betting on elections is
a huge deal
you could argue that the stock market
there's one it's a casino
they're all betting on the outcome of
the election just as much as people
actually betting on that the true lines
um the international
community is fascinated with u.s
politics like think about just think
about if you don't live in the united
states right now what's going on
america was this lighthouse on the hill
and now you read things about social
unrest you read about coronavirus and
and the potential um kind of good or bad
handling of it you read about
the uncertainty in an election you read
about the fact that both political
parties are likely to say
that the election is rigged right now
opera
well this is stuff that we're used to
reading about
happening in other countries right this
stuff is not
uh it is not historically a us-based
thing
and now the rest of the world is saying
oh you
people thought that you were above all
of this you thought you were better than
this
you're no different than any other
country right you have the same problems
and challenges that we have
and so i think there's a lot of people
who are just paying attention and
they're very interested by us politics
um and so why not put some money on it
i think the united states has always
been like that cool kid on instagram
that only posts about
uh really great things happening in
their lives and now
like this year this is like the ugly
like
the bad all that stuff and people just
can't stop watching
yeah it's like a train wreck go ahead
okay
on to some interesting and positive news
insider whispering am i whispering
what insider the parent company to
business insider
closed an all cash deal thursday to buy
a majority stake in morning brew
a media startup that focuses on business
newsletters
and podcasts what do you think
cash cash cash all around me let's go
the deal rich rich
rich af the deal values morning brew at
around 75
million but what i found fascinating is
that they
um morning brew no
morning brew expects to bring in over 20
million dollars in revenue
this year and six million dollars in
profit
that's amazing for a newsletter business
well it's a media company right so yes
they have newsletters but they got a
podcast they got some other stuff
they got joggers supposedly now whatever
look i don't care about all the details
of the deal i'm just happy
for those two guys for those that don't
know austin and alex are
two people that uh planet and i know uh
they built a company since about 2016 i
think
and they just sold the company at a
valuation of 75 million bucks
uh they together own almost the entire
thing
they raise very little money 750 000
only
yeah and they they're they're rich now
there's no way around it they're rich
austin and alex are rich
good for them but they also go for solid
business that a lot of people enjoy
yeah and they should be rich
this is the american dream two and i'm
saying this they probably say it too
two [ __ ] kids in college decided to
start a company and shithead's not a bad
thing it just you don't know anything
when you're 20 21 years old
how do you know anything they started a
company and they figured it out
they built this amazing business that's
profitable
that's got two and a half million people
on their email list
and they figured out how to scale it how
to make it sustainable
how to do all these things that isn't
reliant on them
and guess what happens you make money
somebody came along and said we want
that and we'll pay you for it
and they said dude i'll take that deal
and now they got cash
cash rules everything around me let's go
you ain't know about that you don't know
about that rap life go ahead i do not
know about that rap life but
um but cream okay
i am happy am cass rules everything
around me
are you done yeah i'm just happy
to watch y'all
i'm just happy that they've been able to
build this
with starting with the newsletter that
used to be their core product i think it
still
is and it just shows that there's a lot
of opportunity in this space
guess what you know who randy moss is
no yeah of course not randy mosses was
an nfl wide receiver he was awesome
he's got uh somebody made a song one
time using a bunch of his interviews
and in one of it you know what he says
no great cash homie
that's what they did they got straight
cash go ahead
because they had to get like 75 million
dollars
so they probably got
40 million or more in cash
wow i got what they said
in cash austin alex if you're watching
this leave in the comments how much
bitcoin y'all gonna buy don't make me
call you and convince you
are you done yeah i'm done go ahead
straight cash homie the coronavirus
pandemic is making silicon valley tech
investors
more global in their outlook according
to alex
kyle who is the head of salesforce
ventures international
today it makes no difference to a
valley-based investor if
a company is 30 minutes away or an
eight-hour flight away he said
new data shows that european startups
raised over 2 billion euros
2.3 billion more from u.s investors
between january and october this year
than they did in the same period last
year so i think this is really
interesting because when i was writing
term sheet at fortune
it was always like these european
companies
struggled to raise venture capital
because the vc uh
ecosystem in the in europe is not as
strong as the one in the us
uh investors didn't really wanna us
based investors didn't really want to
invest in european startups because
they're far they're it's not as easily
accessible etcetera
but now with covid i feel like that's
changing and good for the european
startups
yeah i mean look it makes sense from us
of
a perspective of like i don't care where
you are we're all on
zoom like yeah okay that makes sense
look
the internet allows you to build
anything in the world from anywhere in
the world
that's it the internet is an awesome
place
let's go get people who are smart money
so they can build their dreams and if
you build
a great company that is sustainable and
is profitable
somebody will either give you money as a
customer
as an investor or as an acquirer
or in the public markets but you can get
that straight cash homie too
yes yeah see now you're gonna
go ahead next okay something big
happened yesterday
netflix raised the prices of its
standard and premium plans
to 13.99 and 17.99 per month
respectively
prior to thursday those plans were
priced at 12.99
and 15.99 so one dollar for the standard
from for the standard and two dollars
for the premium
what do we think i don't even remember
how much netflix cost
netflix could be thirty dollars a month
and i'd still thought it was 9.99
i think that i paid 9.99 when i signed
up but that's the whole thing
oh wait oh wait the entry-level basic
plan remains at 8.99 per month the same
price that was introduced last year
whatever it is 9.99 11.99
eventually it's going to be 20.99
it doesn't matter because that's why
they keep increasing the prices because
there's obvious
that there's price insensitivity people
are willing to pay more for it so of
course they're gonna keep raising their
prices
but have they added any more value they
don't need to it was underpriced
and plus they added a lot of value
it's a great thing you just go on there
and you can waste a bunch of time
the chicago seven right the trial of the
chicago seven would watch that you like
that right that was very good okay well
what if you had to pay five dollars to
rent that one movie
that's fair okay i'm just an intelligent
person
very intelligent right a unique asteroid
hurtling through space puts our global
economy
to shame with an out of this world
estimated worth of
10 000 quadrillion that's a lot of
commas
cash money cash money um nasa's hubble
telescope has
discovered 16 psyche a rare piece of
heavy metal
that is one of the largest objects in
the solar system's
main asteroid belt orbiting between mars
and jupiter
i like space would you buy it for ten
thousand quadrillion
if i had that kind of money yeah i'd
probably be buying all kinds of crazy
stuff
you you'd go with the okay would you buy
an asteroid
or the t-rex uh t-rex for sure look at
my t-rex
nah but uh asteroid my problem with the
asteroid is like
i can't really show it to people kind of
yeah i own one up there like i think you
can uh you can buy a star
or like sponsor a star and they name it
after you or something
but it's like i like i can't really see
it
you could you could see it sponsor the
sun
be like i paid for that i would like to
own the sun
and if you own the sun that you can shut
it off when you want
be like okay it's night time
you know how space works
okay anthony believes that there is
someone who shuts the sun off
every night for us to go to sleep
around 7pm
all right what's next all right that's
it and i don't have a joke today okay i
have something don't worry i have
something
let me know if you can hear this
garbage disposal
how do you pay man if you don't write
checks how do you pay these guys
straight cash homie
i heard it did you hear it it cash homie
they said he said how do you pay and he
said uh
i i don't pay uh with uh
cash and they said how you pay then he
said straight cash homie
all right all right hold on hold on i
think that i got let me see real quick
if i can find uh oh here we go this is
the song ready
sure call one clap by dj stevenson
selected but before i get the questions
man i'd like to say
something everybody
do what i want to do
[Music]
nobody
everybody
i know about randy moss songs
one clap by dj steve porter go google it
go look on youtube
one flap pull your 84 jerseys out
straight cash homie that's it for lunch
monday today
i'll see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends